y más de la mitad de la población de
australia está en confinamiento debido a
rebrote de la variante delta de kobe 19
la última ciudad en sumarse fue cambiar
la capital del país que entra desde hoy
a un confinamiento de 7 días debido a
cuatro casos nuevos registrados en las
últimas 24 horas pero la peor situación
se está viviendo en sydney capital del
estado de nueva gales del sur que a
pesar de llevar más de un mes y medio
con fuertes restricciones no ha podido
disminuir los contagios tiene 5500 casos
activos y un promedio diario de 300
contagios nuevos queensland de este
estado cuya capital en la ciudad de
brisbane tiene un total de 155 casos
activos y un promedio diario de 10 casos
nuevos aquí en melbourne un capital del
estado de victoria estamos viviendo el
sexto confinamiento desde que inició la
pandemia y el cuarto este año tenemos un
promedio de 20 casos nuevos diarios y en
total 137 casos activos australia empezó
su proceso de vacunación en febrero y
hasta el momento tiene alrededor del 20
por ciento de su población que el 25
millones vacunada con las dos dosis de
astrazéneca y facer esta semana el
gobierno federal que se aprobó la
distribución de la vacuna de moderna que
en próximas semanas se empezará a llegar
al país